we might Tillman is running for Congress
in Colorado as a Democrat he says it's
unwise to arm teachers with firearms
prevent school shootings instead he says
pepper spray ought to be enough to stop
a shooter
to prove it he pepper sprayed himself
watch trust me this will stop anyone in
their tracks
oh and now I just can't see anything
don't try that at home it does raise at
least one question what else is this man
willing to do to become a member of
Congress Levi Tillman joins us tonight
Levi thanks a lot for coming on people
made fun of this I didn't I found it
inspiring people have a dream they'll do
anything to get it I thought this showed
a total commitment to getting elected
and I and I sincerely admired that would
you shave your eyebrows to get elected
to Congress well Tucker thanks for
having me on the show I appreciate it
and the truth is that the response has
been huge to this video and the only
criticisms that we've gotten have come
from too disconnected fantasy lands on
the far left you have people who think
if we stop selling guns than the other
300 plus million guns that are already
in the United States will somehow
disappear and on the far right you have
people who want to play cowboys and
Indians in our schools and classrooms
and they imagine that every school
shooter is a trained commando and that
every teacher should be as well this is
a policy proposal that lives in a
reality and it's meant to solve a real
problem
okay Washington happens you're gonna get
a hold on if you're gonna get elected to
Congress and I think this is you make a
fair point you're gonna need to learn to
answer the question in hand and the
question is would you shave your
eyebrows if I said I can make you
congressmen today are you I came on the
show to talk with you about serious
issues you know one of the biggest is
you can amaze yourself in the face
during that way this is a serious issue
do not understand that 9 I don't
understand those school shootings happen
at a range of less than 8 feet and so
this is well in the range of your young
nation yourself down the fairway hold on
you can't I'm sitting boy you're almost
in Congress just with the speech pattern
I'm impressed by that too what you do is
there anything that you wouldn't do to
get this job and I do think that
commitment is a button I came on here
are you discuss school safety so let me
tell you something else the Department
of Homeland Security has three things
you know you just a reality show running
your hive and dirt and this would have a
last line of defense if you are would
you be where would she be willing to
tase yourself is a gunman who is coming
in to rubber bullets and then there
you're not gonna answer the question I
think you've qualified yourself to
Congress already Tucker I'm supposed to
vote a free answer everybody else up
there this is a serious policy issue and
we are gonna discuss serious policy
questions and I dramatize I love it it
is started seriously by Caroline you
have to go and fortunately great to see
you thanks a lot for doing that